okay let's look at something so in in
your iido
tabaki you will always have some
built-in Yin yields those Yin yields are
going to be used for you
to um measure and adapt to the Y
value of his energy okay so for example
if you watch my if you watch my hands
stop if you watch my hands they're going
to
do various types of circle movements and
if you watch my shoulders you just I
won't do my hands but you watch my
shoulders my shoulders are making my
hands move uh both forward or back or in
or out and you add that it gets pretty
Dynamic okay uh as opposed to over here
like this grabs and you're just here and
you're trying to do these things it
never really changes the relationship
that we have initially so as I as I do
my test saki there's a yield so we look
at this hand even though it's going
forward it's yielding because it's
coming on the inside I'm going to come
on the inside so I come on the inside
you
see and then the same thing is this hand
is coming this way you see that it goes
it's going back
okay
some systems will do it pretty
dynamically in the wrist only okay so
let's say that uh he's doing some sort
of push right and you'll see uh
movements like
that and in that motion do you see how I
have his Center in that motion we just
do it with our body as opposed to just
my wrist moves okay my whole body moves
but again here I have a center again I
used
it so that's why you can't from there
cuz in
that on there cuz in that moment You'
gathered his
Center sometimes it's very small it's
very small and it looks looks like I
just went forward but it's very small
instead can be
big
I want you to pay attention to that
little yield that always happens
boom it's the same thing here that we
were doing the other day you here I went
on the outside there's my yield and now
I know his y value and I match
it you kind of do it internally too and
that's a higher skill so here I'm doing
those
yields uh with a mixture so as I'm
moving my hand into a Yin yield I
am chemically energetically matching his
y value so that I get his Center at the
end of
it but you can do it internally so it
looks like I'm going forward but it's
happening
internally
so even as I'm going back like this to
do it I am internally as he's pushing
it's not that I'm getting out of the way
and trying to do something it's
internally his energy is going past me
okay and as it's going past me
eventually I'll have it and then you'll
have his
Center
internal making
sure now there's a reason why in my
opinion iido doesn't just do
internal although some other Arts do
okay and the reason being so if we're if
we're internal it's true that I have a
center that is true and it is true that
I project I can project him from here so
what I mean is so keep your grip um as I
have him here I can move I can move that
center around well likewise I can
project it too
boom you can pull it too as you're as
you're using your you can pull
it but what we want is I'm going to do
all of those things not in so linear a
way but I'm going to start this
[Music]
rotation which isn't me just moving on
the outside of him it's inside so the
same thing you can project you can move
him
you can move towards
you but we're going to use that seizure
to take him into a
turn but that turn is not an external
turn no matter how much you make it look
like it's something it's not external
it's the same exact thing which is why
you can do it from you can do it from
there you can still do
it
[Music]
in the same way you can do your
Technique is still doing the same
thing you capture on
[Music]
contact it's not that I'm around
here that's different
okay just play with it
so when you're standing you can do this
you can do a lot of those yields with an
actual
step with the weight
shift okay you combine the two the home
P just
remember that um if you don't have the
geometry for
falling you're not going to get your gos
okay for this exercise doesn't matter
you
have
just just training enough for you're
rolling you got to
get
you got to get into that kazushi pattern
so there's my yield but it's not that
I'm just getting out of the way hold
your moving his
cental moving his Center
[Music]
sh
okayy
he